all right let's continue looking and
listening to the sights and sounds
yesterday at the House of
Representatives surrounding this
humiliating embarrassment for
Republicans wherein they failed after
three votes to elect a speaker of the
house so many interesting things going
on and I want to start with multiple
Republicans likening Jim Jordan to
George Washington and and I'm not
talking about you know maybe you think
oh is that like my neighbor George no
we're talking about the first president
of the United States they're comparing
Jim Jordan to George Washington and
acting as if there is a similarity I can
assure you George Washington would not
have looked the other way about alleged
wrongdoing in the wrestling locker room
the way Jim Jordan is accused of doing
but let's put that aside for a moment
congresswoman Lauren bobert is one of
the folks who is defecting seemingly
from supporting Kevin McCarthy for
speaker of the house she appeared on
where is this uh Sean Spicer's show on
Newsmax and she said you know George
Washington did not want to be president
but he did it because it was right
and it's similar
to Jim Jordan uh listen to this there's
uh many people who we could propose I I
am a big proponent of Lee zeldin who
actually won US the majority Jim Banks
is wonderful Kevin Hearn it would be an
amazing speaker an amazing leader Mike
Johnson it could be another option um
but also going back to Jim Jordan George
Washington did not want to be president
of the United States but she did what
was right for his country
uh you know another similarity George
Washington never told the lie and
neither did Jim Jordan except when he
lied four times about did you speak to
Trump on the day of the riots or not
um hard to imagine a more different
individual than George Washington uh
than Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
and this is the result quite frankly
like I know it's just nonsense that just
funnels right out spews out of Lauren
bobert's mouth and we could say David
the analysis can stop there we don't
need to go any further but to some
degree this sort of stuff is the result
of teaching whatever version of History
these Republicans want to be teaching in
school you end up thinking a sketchy
wrestling coach turned congressman who
yells at every interview is in any way
like the first president of the United
States George Washington now it's also
possible that bobert is mentioning
George Washington because she doesn't
know any the other historical figures
always a possibility when someone as
ignorant as bobert but bobert is not the
only one
who is making this George Washington
comparison Scott Perry who is Republican
elect Congressman uh elect uh from
Pennsylvania he went on Fox News and he
also said you know George Washington Jim
Jordan there's really something there
look if you listen to watch the speech
that Jim Jordan gave yeah quite honestly
most Republicans sat there and said oh
my goodness why isn't this guy running
for speaker and while I know Jim would
be reluctant I remind everybody George
Washington was reluctant to when his
country called so a reluctant hero maybe
not the hero they wanted to be
but the hero that their country demanded
that they be
that's very stupid extremely extremely
stupid and here is Lauren bobert later
appearing on Fox News
Brett Bayer mentions you know I think
it's possible Jim Jordan not only isn't
running for the job but doesn't want the
job and bobert goes he may have to do it
he may have to do it and if you heard
from him that he does not want it in any
way shape or form
what do you say I have heard that from
him and uh if we have the numbers then
sorry Jim Jordan we're going to make you
do what's right for the country we love
you now of course it would be very wrong
if Jim Jordan being speaker of the house
is right then I don't know right and
wrong anymore and I know many in my
audience already believe that and they
write to me all the time saying I have
no moral compass but I'm not really
addressing that uh I do not believe Jim
Jordan is going to be the speaker of the
house and in fact if we pull up and I
apologize
um I wanted to find this earlier and I
forgot speaker of the house if we look
at the betting markets on speaker of the
house and let's see there's actually two
different ones here that we can look at
um okay if you look at oh this is old
action I don't have the numbers okay
folks I apologize we if they don't
resolve who the speaker is after today's
votes one of the elements that I will
prepare for you tomorrow I my lack of
professionalism is showing I will
prepare for you tomorrow the betting
markets on who will ultimately be the
Speaker of the House let's now talk
about the fox propaganda machine and
their reaction to this Republican
humiliation
one of our sponsors today is Magic spoon
the breakfast cereal with the crunchy
sweet goodness you love but with high
quality ingredients less sugar and more
protein magic spoon has zero grams of
sugar it's packed with 13 to 14 grams of
protein and just four to five net carbs
so it's great if you're doing keto or
low carb or if just like me you're
trying to limit your sugar intake they
have many unique flavors so you'll never
get bored my personal favorite is maple
waffle but I grew up in New England so
maybe that's why Maple you know they
also have cocoa fruity frosted peanut
butter blueberry muffin honey nut
cookies and cream cinnamon roll
sometimes there's really just no
substitute
for sitting down with a nice bowl of
cereal who doesn't love that when the
mood strikes go for something more
wholesome with plenty of protein and
without all the sugar if you don't love
magic spoon as much as I do and our team
does magic spoon will refund all of your
money no questions asked simply go to
magicspoon.com Pacman you can create a
custom bundle and use the code Pacman
for five dollars off the link is down
below